Tails OS a free based AF operating
system designed to protect you against
malware censorship and surveillance it
was first released in 2009 and became
famous when Edward Snowden used it to
communicate with reporters exposing the
government's Mass surveillance programs
most personal computers are just cool
prisons that track your every movement
and harvest your biometric data so
advertisers can eventually unburden you
from your money Tails OS is a Debian
based Linux distro that boots from a USB
stick to turn any computer into a
temporarily secure machine when you
finally discover the true shape of the
earth you might think you're clever
because you used a private browser and
deleted all the files from your computer
but traces were left behind on disk that
could be recovered via forensic analysis
and now they're going to try to unalive
you Tails helps you avoid this fate
thanks to Amnesia everything you do
disappears automatically when the OS
shuts down because Tails never writes
anything to the hard disk and only runs
from the memory on your computer when
you get a knock at the door
there's no need to rip out your hard
drive and flush it down the toilet
instead just turn the computer off and
all the totally legit it and mundane
things you just did will be lost forever
however it is possible to store some
information on the USB like browser
bookmarks or documents that you want to
persist between sessions and of course
they're encrypted automatically when you
boot it up you'll find your favorite
canoe utilities but also privacy focused
software like the tour browser which
routes internet traffic through the Tor
Network consisting of multiple layers of
encrypted relays where no individual
relay knows both where you're coming
from and where you're going to conceal
your location IP address and usage in
fact any application that tries to
access the internet without the tour
network is automatically blocked on
Tails this makes it a great option for
journalists working on sensitive topics
victims of domestic abuse or anyone who
enjoys truly free software where free
means freedom what will you do without
freedom to get started grab a USB stick
with at least eight gigabytes of memory
then download the version that matches
your current OS now verify the file to
ensure that it wasn't corrupted during
download then use a tool like etcher to
safely flash it on the USB stick next
make sure you have the official startup
instructions on a separate device then
on Windows hold down the the shift key
while clicking on the restart button
from the start menu then use the option
to reboot from a device this will bring
up a boot menu where you can select the
USB stick at which point you can select
Tails from the bootloader and now we're
officially running Tails go through the
initial setup and most importantly make
sure you have a good connection to the
tour Network congratulations you now
have a private and Anonymous computer
everything you do now is stored in
random access memory and not on disk in
addition when tail shuts down it will
overwrite most of the ram to prevent a
cold boot attack where someone extracts
a memory dump from the ram which is
often done in digital forensics to catch
the bad guys this has been Tails OS in
100 seconds but don't tell anybody I
told you about it thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one
[Music]